dr anthony fauci the top infectious
disease doctor in the country
has revealed in an interview over the
weekend that he and his family
have been receiving serious threats as
he continues to try to fight the
coronavirus pandemic in the united
states
on the same day that we learned about
the threats
to dr fauci and his family the united
states
set another single day record with more
than
77 000 new coronavirus cases just shy of
78 000 new coronavirus cases
and the day after we learned that dr
fauci was being threatened
and his family was being threatened as
we hit a record
of single day new cases donald trump
went golfing
for the 282nd time
of his presidency dr fauci saying to
david axelrod on
ax's podcast quote there are people who
get really angry at thinking
i'm interfering with their life because
i'm pushing a public health
agenda the kind of not only hate mail
but actual serious threats against me
are not good
i mean really is this the united states
of america
but it's real it really is real
this has gotten so bad that dr anthony
fauci
a nearly 80 year old infectious disease
doctor who's been working for both
democratic and republican presidents for
what is it 40 years at this point
it's gotten so bad that dr fauci and his
family
now have a security detail
should be embarrassed donald trump and
his press secretary
are out there talking about oh paw
patrol
is cancelled some show paw patrol
coronavirus is raging and the top guy
actually fighting the virus while trump
talks about paw patrol dr fauci
needs security for himself and for his
family
because of threats against them and
people wonder why we why
why don't we have all these cases why do
we have a hundred and we're about to
cross 150
000 dead americans while so many
countries have it under control
this is why this is why is the world
ever going to forgive us for this
i saw someone on twitter say in response
to
uh the the threats against fouchy and
you know everything that's going on
too bad we don't have a vaccine for
stupidity well we sort of do
it's called education right real quality
education
with uh people being taught media
literacy
and critical thinking that is a vaccine
against being victim of disinformation
propaganda we're lacking it in a lot of
the country now i
you know whenever i say this educators
write to me they say david you know
we're doing a good job here there
no doubt there is no doubt that there is
plenty of
great education in the united states but
too much of the united states is
lacking it we know what the vaccine is
to stupidity
we can produce it in mass quantities but
we don't invest nearly enough in it as a
country i'm talking about education here
and lots of parents tell their kids you
don't really need
that education and this is where we are
today
i made a mistake early on in this
pandemic
and i've been reading a bunch of
interesting pieces about it over the
last week
from others who made the same mistake we
didn't think that something
so cut and dry like a medical crisis
such as the one we're experiencing would
see the country so divided along the
typical
political lines where one side says
health is the priority listen to doctors
take care of others trust in the
scientific method
empathy etc and another side would lead
protests against masks spread conf
conspiracy theories about dr fauci and
bill gates
show up filming at walmart to show how
patriotic they are by refusing to wear a
mask
i underestimated it i thought this would
bring people together
and we would do the right things and put
those stupid political
disagreements aside but clearly i was
wrong and
to go back to the fouchy piece dr fauci
has been thrown to the wolves by this
administration with donald trump
criticizing fouchy rather than
criticizing fauci's detractors
the white house piled on publishing a
document of
what is essentially opposition research
about dr fauci
listing things the white house released
to the media
a document saying look at all this stuff
vouch you got wrong
well what about trump saying 15 cases
will soon be zero there's no
accountability for that
what about trump saying all of the
things that he has said can you imagine
dr
fauci and bill gates two of the people
pouring
time and money in gates case into
solving infectious disease for no
personal gain bill gates donating what
is it is it hundreds of millions at this
point
uh to vaccination and dealing with
disease dr fauci is nearly 80 he's a
high risk individual which he says is
why he's not stepping on a plane or
going to a restaurant
and yet he's seemingly working 24 7 and
they are attacked
conspiracy theories created about them
has about one third of the country gone
functionally insane
defining functional insanity is tough
but the gist of it is if you're
functionally insane you can basically
exist in society in a semi-normal way
like you could probably hold a job for
example
you're keeping your kids alive well
enough to to raise them to adulthood
that they may have some weird ideas but
you that you're keeping them alive
but then in practice they live believing
completely delusional things like dr
fauci is helping bill gates's population
control
uh wet dream agenda uh by
planning to rfid chip people with a
vaccine or
masks are making me lose my rights or
depriving me of
oxygen or it's reasonable to scream at a
costco employee
because i don't want to wear a mask and
i think coronavirus is a
is a hoax is there a sort of functional
insanity here
that we have to deal with unclear but
i feel terribly for dr fauci and again
is the world going to forgive us for
this this has been one of the largest
mishandlings
of anything i mean listen katrina was a
disaster the way that george bush
handled katrina there is no excuse
whatsoever
but compare the scale of what we're
dealing with now
and to call this trump's katrina
it understates actually what's going on
without
in any way minimizing the absolute
disaster that was george w bush's
handling of katrina
i don't even know what to compare it to
at this point in time and again
today probably by the time you hear this
we likely will have
surpassed the 150 000 death
milestone i don't know if we deserve to
be forgiven
unfortunately for what this
administration has done or better said
not done in response to this virus we'll
take a quick break
and be back right after this with the
latest from portland where the mayor has
actually been tear gassed if you can
believe that
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for their completely
free service at privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something
online or on the phone instead of
actually using your real credit card
number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create
out of thin air it'll even autofill the
card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want
privacy also offers a ten dollar a month
plan that gives you one percent cash
back and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a 25
a month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create
60 card numbers a month and much more
but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with the free plan you'll
protect your financial info companies
can't charge you unexpectedly and like i
said
you'll get five dollars to spend when
you sign up at
privacy.com slash pacman